.
>> Todd: BROOKE SINGMAN, THANK
YOU.  THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING
MIXED REVIEWS FROM THE MEDIA ON
INFLATION MESSAGING.
LISTEN.
>> FIRST IT WAS TRANSITORY AND
THEN INFLATION WAS GOOD AND THEN
CORPORATE GREED AND NOW PUTIN.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE MIND
THIS AND MORE LIKELY WILLING TO
TAKE A HIT AT THE PUMP.
PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE IS GREAT WAY
TO MESSAGE IT.
>> Carley: JOE CONCHA JOINS US
TO BREAK IT DOWN.
GOOD ATTEMPTS AT MESSAGING IT,
BUT IT IS A LIE ISSUE GAS PRICES
HAVE BEEN GOING UP SINCE HE'S
BEEN IN OFFICE, SO ARE PEOPLE
BUYING IT?
>> Joe: I WOULD THINK SOBER --
IT IS EARLY AND SANE PEOPLE ARE
NOT.
I DON'T SOUND SOBER.
IT IS THE BLAME, PUTIN IS THE
NEW TRUMP.
INFLATION RISING FOR A YEAR,
BLAME PUTIN.
GAS PRICES HAVE BEEN RISING
SINCE NOVEMBER OF 2020, BLAME
PUTIN.
CRIME, BLAME REPUBLICANS FOR
WANTING TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
THE BORDER, BLAME TRUMP,
DISAGREEMENT AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, BLAME PARENTS, GOOD
MOVE.
DEBACLE OF THE WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN, BLAME THE AFGHAN
MILITARY AND BLAME TRUMP FOR
FUN.
IT IS A JOKE, TO YOUR QUESTION,
CARLEY, NOBODY IS LAUGHING OR
BUYING IT, I WOULD THINK.
THE FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID THIS AFTER
THE 2008 FINANCIAL CRISIS.
YOU NEVER WANT A SERIOUS CRISIS
TO GO TO WASTE, THAT IS WHAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS DOING,
TAKING ACCOUNTABILITY OFF
THEMSELVES WHILE PUSHING GREEN
ENERGY AND TELLING EVERYONE TO
BUY A TESLA, WHICH AMERICANS CAN
TOTALLY AFFORD STARTING AT
$50,000 A POP.
>> NEXT FRIDAY IS DAY AFTER ST.
PATRICK'S DAY, I EXPECT YOU TO
BE DRUNK THEN ISSUE NOT THIS
MORNING.
>> Joe: I KNOW, RIGHT.
>> Todd: SPEAKING OF SOUNDING
DRUNK, ROLL TAPE.
>> IS THE UNITED STATES WILLING
TO MAKE A SPECIFIC ALLO OCCASION
FOR UKRAINIAN REFUGEES?
>> OKAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Vice President Harris: A
FRIEND IN NEED IS A FRIEND
INDEED.
>> Todd: THIS IS EVERY SINGLE
TIME NOW AND THIS HAS LIFE AND
DEATH CONSEQUENCES, HOW
EMBARRASSING IS IT THAT WE PUT
HER FORWARD AS OUR
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE WORLD
STAGE WHEN LITERALLY LIFE AND
DEATH IS AT STAKE?
>> Joe: I THINK, TODD, WE CAN
SAFELY SAY KAMALA HARRIS IS NOT
EVER GOING TO BE AN ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAD ZELENSKYY'S FORMER
SPOKESPERSON TWEETING, IT WOULD
BE A TRAGEDY IF THIS WOMAN EVER
WON THE PRESIDENCY, AND IT IS
APPARENT THIS IS VERY UNSERIOUS
PERSON IN OVER HER HEAD, THIS IS
A TWEET, YOU ARE GOOD.
ONE OF OUR GREAT NO NONSENSE WAR
REPORTERS ON THE GROUND SAID WE
HEARD DIPLOMATIC AND POLITICAL
SPEAK FROM VICE PRESIDENT
HARRIS, THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
DON'T NEED THAT AND SAID HER
REMARKS WERE DETACHED FROM
REALITY.
IT IS HORRIFIC.
38% APPROVAL, HIGHER THAN I
THOUGHT.
THAT IS WHAT SHE'S PULL NOTHING
HER HOME STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
THE BLUEST OF BLUE STATES.
MANY DEMOCRATS HAVE BIDEN
REMORSE IN TERMS OF HER BEING
OUR VICE PRESIDENT AND FOR GOOD
REASON, GUYS.
>> Carley: THAT IS RIGHT.
JULIA, FORMER PRESS SECRETARY
FOR ZELENSKYY POSTED A TWEET
ABOUT THAT MOMENT WHERE THE VICE
PRESIDENT LAUGHED, DID HE
MENTION THAT?
IT WOULD BE TRAJ ED FETHIS WOMAN
WON THE PRESIDENCY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE WATCHING HER
AND THAT MOMEN